overseas to ukraine now where the
government says russian forces have been
suffering setbacks around the key city
of harkeev the footage you're looking at
now shows appar apparently shows burnt
out russian vehicles seeming to back up
the ukrainian president's claims his
forces are pushing russian troops
further away from that the country's
second largest city but russia has made
gains elsewhere in the east and charlie
daggett reports now from inside ukraine
when nadia and her husband found out
where the airstrike came down in the
eastern town of bakhmut they rushed to
this neighborhood as fast as they could
and soon discovered the bodies of their
relatives
they were kind
very good people she said
the ukrainian military has little
defense against russia's overwhelming
firepower
where the fight has become a bloody
battle of trench warfare drone footage
alleges to show a russian tank destroyed
near kharkiv ukrainian soldiers who
drove out russians northeast of the city
found rows of shot up cars scattered
clothes a baby seat a stroller apparent
evidence of civilians killed even as
they tried to flee and yet the russian
offensive in donbass has been relentless
flattening small towns in the march
toward the strategic cities of
kramatorsk and sloveonsk where we found
heavily fortified cities protected by
well-armed troops endless bunkers
concrete blocks and anti-tank defenses
ringing the outskirts and it doesn't
stop there this fighting position is
right in the center of the city if
russian ground forces were to advance
they would face a whole network of these
dug-in trenches
and they are everywhere soldiers say the
russian invaders would face guerrilla
warfare at every turn vladimir kutnenko
is a medic who's been battling russian
separatists since 2014. have you treated
any russian soldiers
yes yes of course of course
we provide them with the full range of
medical support he said we exchanged
them for our prisoners of war but our
prisoners of war are returned in a
terrible medical condition
and as the brutal battle nears soldiers
here say they know the most difficult
days lie ahead for cbs mornings charlie
dagda in sloveonsk eastern ukraine